Most people know that Apple MacBook laptops
are more expensive than many of the Windows
options, and a lot of Windows laptops pack
better performance specs while being cheaper
But for some reason, a lot of people are still
choosing to pay hundreds of dollars more for
a MacBook, so why is that?
And why have we seen so many Mac Users who
switched to good windows laptops because of
Apple’s high prices, go back after just
a few months?
If you’re not a fan of Apple devices, hold
on just a second before you dislike this video
and leave because chances are, there's probably
a few good reasons that you’ve never even
thought about.
Here are 18 reasons why MacBooks are so expensive,
let’s start off with the hardware.
Most people who have used a MacBook trackpad
would agree that Apple’s force-touch trackpads
are by far, the best you can get.
They don’t actually move or click, they
use a pane of glass with sensors underneath
that sense pressure from your finger, and
the taptic engine below it vibrates to give
you haptic feedback that feels like a click
so with a perfect feel anywhere you press
and it can even sense pressure for 3D touch.
These awesome trackpads cost much more than
the plastic ones with springs in other laptops.
Apple also uses really fine-tuned high-quality
speakers that sound incredible and pack a
lot of volume for the size.
Just listen to this comparison of Apple’s
2017 MacBook Pro and Dell’s newest 2019
XPS 13.
As you’ve heard, the MacBook Pro’s speakers
sound much better in every way.
And check out that same MacBook Pros microphone
quality compared to the new Dell XPS..
Yep, there’s a huge difference.
And that’s something you can’t see on
a spec sheet.
Apple also packs in additional custom chips
that weren’t cheap to develop, like Apple’s
T2 chip, which gives extra features like added
security through the secure enclave’s end-to-end
encryption and things like HEVC encoding,
making a huge difference in encoding speed.
Although the MacBook displays might not be
the highest resolution out there, Apple’s
MacBook displays are much brighter than the
average Windows laptop,
and they also use very high-quality coatings
that reduce reflectivity by a lot, so they’re
much easier to use in bright conditions or
outside.
MacBooks Pros are also incredibly color accurate,
supporting P3 wide-color gamut, which has
around 25% more colors compared to sRGB.
One thing many don’t consider is that Apple’s
MacBooks are machined out of a solid block
of aluminum, which is not only expensive for
the materials alone but also more costly to
manufacture but result in a very solid chassis
that has a premium feel.
Because of this, Apple was able to create
custom stacks of batteries that are sized
perfectly to fit the interior of the aluminum
chassis, so we get more battery life out of
very thin laptops, but do cost more than standard
batteries.
Every
single MacBook since 2013 packed top-of-the-line
SSD flash storage, while there are still some
Windows laptops to this day that come with
really slow physical hard drives, and if they
come with SSDs, many times, they’re nowhere
near as fast as Apple’s SSDs.
On top of they give you options to spec up
to 4TB of extremely fast storage where many
windows laptops are limited to much less,
but admittedly the prices are really marked
up and you’ll end up with a crazy expensive
laptop.
Apple’s MacBook Pros also feature more Thunderbolt
3 ports that you can get on Windows laptops.
There are currently no Windows laptops that
we know of that have 4 full-speed Thunderbolt
3 ports like the 15” MacBook Pro does, and
that requires extra Thunderbolt chips from
Intel.
Although not everyone likes Apple’s Touch
Bar, and personally we’re also not fans,
but they’re still incredibly high-quality
touch-screen OLED Displays, packing Touch
ID with end-to-end encryption which adds on
extra cost compared to windows laptops.
Speaking of encryption, Let's move onto the
software.
Apple focuses on privacy, making everything
on your MacBook as secure as possible, and
they never sell any of your data like some
other companies do, so they have to earn their
full profit from the laptop itself.
Apple’s macOS is only available on Apple
MacBooks, so that allows them to charge more
for their laptops since if you need MacOS
there's no competition.
On the Windows laptop side there's many manufacturers
so they have to lower their prices to compete.
Since MacOS is only available on a small number
of machines, This limited number of components
means that apps and drivers are very optimized
to make the most out hardware, because of
this, software issues are less common and
old machines still run fast, which really
improves resale value meaning Apple can charge
more for new ones.
With MacOS you also get free major updates
every year, with a bunch of new features.
Whereas, when a new version of Windows comes
out, you have to pay for it.
Along with that, When you buy a MacBook you
get many work apps similar to Microsoft Word,
powerpoint and excel.
Microsoft, on the other hand, charges for
all of those on top of your laptop purchases.
You also don’t have to download additional
apps like PDF readers or video players that
can open a variety of formats, Apple supports
those files out of the box.
It's nice to have these for free, including
any future updates but this does contribute
to higher base laptop prices.
And finally, let’s touch on customer service.
Apple is also the only laptop manufacturer
that has thousands of physical stores all
over the world, which makes it much easier
to get support or repairs.
And they even have a no questions asked 14-day
return policy, without any return shipping
costs or other fees.
Returns aren’t as easy with Windows laptops,
and a lot of them charge 15% restocking fees.
Apple doesn’t do that, so they take the
loss themselves.
There's no question that Apple laptops cost
a lot more money, but hopefully, this video
helps you to see a few reasons why that price
is often higher than the competition.
Judging off of the spec sheet, often times
we are shocked by what Apple charges for the
base CPU and GPU spec, but once you compare
the hardware, software, and all of the little
details that you won’t see on the spec sheet,
it starts to make more sense.
Of course, not everyone cares for these included
features, so a less expensive and more customizable
Windows Laptop still appeals to a lot of people
out there, and to them, the higher price of
a MacBook is not worth it.
Let us know your thoughts down in the comments
section below.
Do you pay the higher price for Mac’s? and
if you do, why?
And If you don’t, let us know why.
We would love to hear your opinion.
Make sure to tap that like button and click
the circle above to subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one.